Growing on tall shrubs with dense foliage,
the small, red, mildly sweet berries known
as miracle fruit seemingly magically can turn
sour flavors sweet.
The plant that produces the berries, Synsepalum
Dulcificum, is native to West Africa, where
the fruit was traditionally used to sweeten
palm wine and make soured cornbread more palatable.
Growing best in acidic soil in tropical zones,
the coffee-sized berries were introduced to
Europeans by the explorer Chevalier des Marchais.
So how does it work?
The exact mechanisms here aren’t fully understood,
but, in a nutshell, the fruit gets its sweetening
properties from miraculin, a glycoprotein
in the berry that binds to sweet receptors
on the tongue.
As to how the miraculin then makes sour things
taste sweet, it appears to relate to the pH
of the miraculin (which is neutral) and sour
foods (which are acidic).
More specifically, when the miraculin binds
to the sweet receptors in the tongue, it is
mostly inert until it comes in contact with
acidic substances.
When that happens, the miraculin changes structure
slightly, with the result being the sweet
receptors it is bound to become activated.
Because miraculin binds so strongly to the
sweet receptors on the tongue, the berry does
not have to be eaten with the sour food, and
the sweetening effect may last as much as
30-60 minutes after chewing the berries.
The duration of the effect depends on factors
including the concentration of the miraculin,
how long it was in contact with the tongue
and the concentration of the acid in the otherwise
sour food.
Not a subtle effect, the perceived sweetness
produced by the miracle fruit can be remarkable
– equivalent to up to a 17% sucrose solution.
For reference here, the equivalent sucrose
solution for typical soft drinks is only about
10%.
The effect is things like Tabasco sauce reportedly
changing flavor to that of doughnut glaze,
among a myriad of other weird taste alterations.
To date, the miracle fruit has yet to be developed
into a commercially-viable non-caloric sugar
substitute in the United States, although
an attempt was made in the 1970s.
However, the day before the product was to
launch under the brand name Miralin, the FDA
suddenly switched from original plans to classify
it as generally recognized as safe (GRAS)
to classifying it as a food additive (which
meant years of further testing to be deemed
safe).
This was a highly controversial move given
that the berries had been regularly eaten
for centuries in Africa without apparent ill
effect.
The project backers lacked the funding to
conduct the years of testing needed and Miralin
ultimately folded.
However, because of the circumstances of the
FDA’s decision-making process, it was suggested
that the sugar industry flexed its political
muscles to sabotage the project.
As such, using the Freedom of Information
Act (FOIA), Miralin ultimately requested documents
related to the FDA’s processing of their
product.
Fanning the conspiracy theory flames, when
the files were produced, most of the documents
were inexplicably completely blacked out,
and there was no mention anywhere of why the
FDA suddenly chose to switch from a GRAS classification
to classifying the substance as a food additive.
Whatever the case, the berry has been classified
as a harmless additive in Japan, where researches
are fiddling with it using recombinant technology.
For instance, using genetic modification,
they have managed to produce lettuce that
expresses miraculin equivalent to one miracle
berry with just two grams of lettuce leaves.
In 2009, an oncologist at Miami’s Mount
Sinai Medical Center also filed an investigational
new drug application with the United States
Food and Drug Administration (USDA) for the
use of the miracle fruit with chemotherapy
patients.
From anecdotal evidence, the oncologist had
discovered that some patients found it helped
counteract the metallic taste byproduct
of chemotherapy.